this video is brought to you by news
voice the news is broken almost all US
media is owned by just a handful of big
corporations fake news obviously a huge
problem as well and finding something
unbiased can be pretty darn tricky news
voices revolutionising the news
landscape it's an app that gives you a
personalized news feed by aggregating
major news sites as well as
international and independent media it
gives some much-needed balance each news
story shows multiple sources which are
all tags with their bias and perspective
the news effects almost everything in
our lives and what we hear and read
shapes which persons we trust what we
eat what we buy how we vote even how we
think news voice is created by its
readers as you can upvote stories that
you find interesting so more people will
see them it's essentially a democratized
platform for news plus it saves you time
you can get all of the news all of the
sources in one app so that you can be
better informed oh and it's also totally
free so does that anyway get started
with news voice today for free through
the link below it's available on both
Google Play and the App Store and let's
get into the video
[Applause]
[Music]
with about a million diagnosed cases the
United States is suffering a severe
thrashing from coronavirus at the time
of making this video more than 22
thousand people had died in New York
State alone from covert 19 it's a
situation that's in the same way as has
happened in many other places around the
globe has forced the governor of New
York State Andrew Cuomo to declare the
closure of schools and shops we are now
the epicenter of this crisis New York
Mayor Bill DeBlasio at a press
conference Friday the consequences of
the corona virus reaching all corners of
US society including some that I'm sure
would never have crossed your minds for
example it is clear that this virus does
not respect walls or electric fences so
one of the big concerns facing many
states is in prisons and within the
inmate population and don't forget we're
talking about the United States the
country with the highest number of
prisoners on the planet more than 2
million people are behind bars it's a
situation that opens the door to
potential mass contagion uncontrollable
riots or even the lack of enough staff
to take care of these places all of this
has led to 15 states having to put in
place extraordinarily tough measures
that even prohibited the access of
lawyers to prisons
and it doesn't end there many counties
are reevaluating their arrest policies
in a way that I swear will leave many of
you aghast for example in Baltimore one
of the 25 most dangerous cities in the
world charges are no longer being files
for drug possession or supply offenses
or the issues related to the world's
oldest trade that is the authorities
have decided to look the other way for
the duration of the health crisis that's
not all not only is it about putting as
few people in jail as possible but some
states like Montana are taking it a step
further and have already discussed the
idea of starting to release as many
inmates as possible especially those who
are convicted of nonviolent crimes who
account for about half of the entire
prison population universities and
hotels you can close I'm left with
people I can't send home says sheriff
dark as we told you the corona virus is
reaching every corner of US society and
the Navy is no exception
[Music]
not even the USS Theodore Roosevelt's
one of the all-powerful Nimitz class
nuclear-powered aircraft carriers has
managed to dodge the pandemic in
mid-march while doing maneuvers in the
South China Sea the corona virus boarded
the Roosevelt ends the nightmare began
barely a week later a report in the form
of a letter from the carrier's own
captain was leaked to the press in it
captain Rocha alerted his colleagues and
superiors to the unsustainable situation
on board the aircraft carrier because of
coronavirus and urged disembarking the
entire crew as soon as possible in order
to curb the contagion
however the story didn't end well
despite having the support of his
superiors and his crew the White House
terminated captain Crozier's commands of
the carrier the reason while they
claimed his letter incited alarmism the
thing is soon after Navy secretary
himself resigns we are not at war
sailors do not need to die Bret Crozier
former captain of the aircraft carrier
USS Theodore Roosevelt and so we go from
prisons to the Navy to the next census
for the first time in its 230 year
history the statistical documents may be
in danger
and yes okay so many of you might be
thinking well Simon a census I mean how
on earth can that be a priority right
now right but this is not just any
census it costs over fifteen billion
dollars making it the most expensive
census in the world it's produced every
ten years and the results serve to
define the entire political architecture
of the country we're talking for example
about the distribution of seats in
Congress or the distribution of
Delegates by state in the presidential
elections once again as you can see the
coronavirus crisis is reaching into
every corner of the country but at this
point many of you might be wondering
faced with all of this mess what has the
Trump administration's response been to
this crisis how far does the power of
the President of the United States reach
in such situations which states are
doing better and which aren't doing
worse well let's take a look at the
ultimate authority President of the
United States has the authority to do
what the president has the authority to
do which is very powerful the president
of the United States calls the shots if
we weren't here for the states you would
have had a problem in this country like
you've never seen people somebody's the
president of the United States the
authority is Tony
Donald Trump's response Donald Trump's
position on the coronavirus has done
more laps than a Formula One car on the
Monte Carlo circuit and that makes us
wonder has the White House been
sufficiently prepared for the impact of
this pandemic exactly how far does the
federal administration's capacity reach
well this seems to be something that
causes a lot of confusion so let me
explain
although the President of the United
States is the one in the international
press who gets all the front pages the
truth is that his Rowland's that of the
federal governments within US borders
are actually quite limited for example
in general trade issues are the
responsibility of Congress and decisions
in health or emergency situations fall
primarily to state governors indeed even
in the face of major catastrophes it is
the governors themselves who must ask
the federal government for help if they
deem it appropriate
so as much as Donald Trump thinks he is
the Yankee version of Xi Jingping
presidents who can do and undo things at
will the truth is that the US
Constitution leaves him very little room
Hamilton and Jefferson and Madison in
Washington they wrote a document that's
called the Constitution of the United
States and it is an explicit and
intricate balance of power between the
federal government and the state
governments and it says the federal
government does not have absolute power
so is the exact opposite that the
president said the authority is total it
says that would be a king we would have
had King George Washington we didn't
have King George Washington and we don't
have King Trump
we are president from the States created
the federal government not the other way
around we have the Tenth Amendment that
is explicit certain responsibilities and
state responsibilities health welfare
quarantine those are health
responsibilities so the president should
not even think of going there
[Music]
so then does that mean that Trump has
his hands tied that his administration
just doesn't work well no of course not
the mere fact that they were able to
activate the war economy proves this by
the way this is a topic that we will be
dedicating an entire video to in the
next few days so do not forget to
subscribe to visual politic if you
haven't done so already the fact is that
although the power of the federal
government is generally quite limited in
the case of the corona virus crisis the
role of several federal agencies has
been key we're talking about
organizations like FEMA CDC and the FDA
three Trump administration led agencies
that during these crises have been a
real disaster yes a real disaster in
early 2020 when the existence of this
epidemic became widely known the FDA the
Food and Drug Administration decided
that no testing kits from any other
country were to be authorized in other
words the US was going to develop its
own test a project that would also be
led exclusively by the government itself
as a result the FDA instructed the CDC
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention another public agency to
develop a test for coronavirus at the
same time and pay attention here it
forbade any other institution by the
private such as pharmaceutical or public
companies like many laboratories to
develop this test so it seemed the
federal government's wanted a monopoly
all for itself
and it's at this point that this is
where the disaster really began from
mid-january to February 28th the CDC
produced 160,000 tests which doesn't
sound too bad but hold on a second
because of those 160,000 tests only
4,000 could be used and the rest attempt
to just be thrown away why well because
most of the tests yielded inconclusive
results basically the tests failed more
than a fairground shotgun apparently
from contamination CDC labs in Atlanta
in other words it was a mess and a
colossal one of that after Trump
promised quote anybody can get
coronavirus testing patients and doctors
still complain of robots while CDC
coronavirus tests stalled for six weeks
a German lab made 1.4 million tests
finally off to some mess up the CDC gave
in and the government allowed the other
public laboratories to try and develop
their own products what's more the FDA
also allowed large pharmaceutical
companies like Roche to give it a try so
those six crucial weeks were just thrown
away plainly because the federal
government wanted to reserved the
spotlight for itself now I don't know
about you but I don't see what was wrong
with allowing other institutions or
private companies to develop their own
tests it just seems crazy that that
wasn't allowed but listen this was
really just the beginning we also have
the case of FEMA the Federal Emergency
Management Agency which is the body
responsible for distributing health
equipment states requesting their
assistance well it looks like this
organization is also having a tough time
in an interview on CNN on March the 22nd
beat again or the director of FEMA
acknowledged that the total lack of
organization was such that they did not
even know a stock of materials that the
agency handled that is to say they had
no idea what capacity they had to deal
with the situation and take notes
because we're not just talking about
January or even February this was at the
end of March moreover their lack of
foresight has created a lot of problems
for FEMA when it comes to buying health
supplies basically they were too late
and now supplies are scarce
how many masks does the federal
government have right now and when can
they get to local hospitals well when it
comes to supplies we have been shipping
from the national stockpile our four
weeks of the mission do you have any
specific numbers on how many masks the
federal government has been able to
acquire and how many have gone out the
door to hospitals you have you been a
rough number I can't give you a rough no
vote you understand though of course
that the inability of the federal
government to give a number in terms of
masks alarms people it makes people
concerned that there aren't masks going
out the door then there are the airports
where health controls weren't noticeable
for their absence at this point given
the disastrous track record of these
agencies that lack of airport prevention
and the influence of their political
discourse the federal government's
ability to act against coronavirus is
really quite unlimited and that leads us
directly to a key question what role are
the individual states playing
the United States really United we've
seen that FEMA is having a lot of
trouble buying health supplies but
they're not the only ones
from the moment the coronavirus began to
show itself as a real and potentially
very serious problem the states
themselves also began on masse to turn
to a market already scarce and supplies
to buy materials which led to them to
have to bid against each other in a
desperate battle to get any possible
protective material at whatever the cost
the result was that within a matter of
days prices rose astronomically for New
York 58 cent medical masks now priced at
$7 50 each Bloomberg look it's important
to note the basic reason the prices
skyrocketed is that buyers themselves
for states were willing to pay a lot
more to snatch supplies from other
customers that is from other states it's
simply the result of scarcity the
question of basic economics supply and
demand but let's not get distracted the
point is that right now New York is the
epicenter of the coronavirus within the
United States what's interesting is that
despite this New Yorkers approval rating
of their governor Democrat Andrew Cuomo
is sky-high New York State is even being
presented by some media as a role model
of crisis management but hold on a
moment because as we say around here all
that glitters is not gold
the New York governor's and trembles
when it came to closing schools across
the state and he resisted for days
before finally decree ingly confinement
order in facts if we have visual politic
at to choose the governor to give an
award to we would go for a much less
media popular case that one who deserves
all of our recognition and that's Mike
DeWine the governor of Ohio the 73 year
old Republican who ignored Donald Trump
himself it may not make headlines but
Douai not was the first governor in the
entire country to have no hesitation in
shutting down schools across his state
you could say that from the very first
moment this governor took the bull by
the horns faced with the danger of a
looming pandemic he closed bars and
restaurants asked all the universities
in the state to suspend face-to-face
classes and addressed citizens asking
them to forget about attending mass
sporting events all this when there were
only a dozen confirmed cases and zero
people had died in a high of at the time
it's give you a comparison Isabelle Diaz
is othes the president of the Spanish
region of Madrid which is one of the
most affected regions in the world
announced the closure of schools on
March the 9th by which time Madrid had
already accumulated almost 600 positive
cases and more than a dozen deaths
mistakes that I've made throughout my
career have generally been because I
didn't have enough facts I didn't dig
deep enough so I made up my mind I was
going to have the best information the
best data available Mike DeWine
and that's not all when Donald Trump set
out to try and opened the economy for
Easter to whine very elegantly replied
that he was not convinced but first
things first when people are dying when
people don't feel safe the economy is
not going to come back Mike DeWine but
if we have the good example I think we
also have to look at a bad one
if we had to give a rotten tomato award
to a governor for his or her management
during this crisis that person would
most likely be Florida Governor Ron de
santis Republican Trump supporter to the
core and you will see that unlike other
governors De Santis turned to deaf ear
to the expert information that was
available and he merely followed the
president's recommendations to me letter
yes Florida closed some beaches in some
box but while half the states that are
ready to create stay-at-home orders many
Florida beaches were still full of
tourists and if you consider the Florida
is considered a pensioners paradise in
the United States you can get an idea of
the potential risks this governor's
decisions have caused finally on April
the first in the face of the escalation
of events the governor was forced to
decree the order to stay at home and
impose mandatory quarantines on people
entering from other states such as New
York in other words he was slower than a
tortoise with rheumatism
anyway there you can see two states
acting very differently and throughout
the crisis in the United States it's the
governors who are the main players that
said Trump's political influence
is more than obvious since you know that
this is an election year which makes the
president very very nervous
and of course news like this doesn't
help us now has 22 million unemployed
wiping out a decade of job gains
Washington Post and here is where the
new White House political strategy for
the 2020 election rears its head a
health level strategy that reinforces
the idea that China and the World Health
Organization are the big culprits in all
of this
Trump halts World Health Organization
funding over handling of coronavirus
outbreak CNN which may be true but of
course that doesn't erase your
accountability if you've been looking
the other way does it and in this crisis
the US federal government hasn't exactly
been a shining star shall we say
and then thinking further down the track
in terms of the economy or well look at
these messages liberate Michigan
liberate Minnesota liberate Virginia and
save your great Second Amendment it is
under siege with this speech what Trump
and his campaign team are after is
making it clear that if economic damage
occurs it will be because of the
governors who ignored him even if the
governors of these states are acting on
what international experience says they
have to deal with the problem of
internal criticism anyway what will the
Trump administration's next move be what
are the consequences of this entire
crisis for the US economy could all of
this cost Trump the presidency well
leave your answer in the comments below
and I really do hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit like if you did and
don't forget to subscribe to brand new
videos also please do check out our
fantastic sponsor for this episode news
voice you I'm linking to you below thank
you for watching and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice you can join us
at reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
you